الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استقيم اعتدل استو سو
الصف
الله
اكبر
ا الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واعلموا انما غنمت الله
وما انزلنا على عبدنا يوم الفرقان يوم
التقى
الجمعان والله على كل شيء
قدير اذ انتم بالعدوه الدنيا وهم بالعدوه
القصوى والركب اسفل
منكم ولو تواعدتم لاختلفتم في الميعا ولكن
ليقضي الله امرا كان
مفعولا ليهلك من هلك عن
بينه ليهلك من هلك عن
بينه ويحيا من حي عن بينه وان الله لسميع
عليم اذ يريكهم الله في منامك
قليلا ولو اراكهم كثيرا لفشلتم ولتنازعتم
في الامر
ولكن الله سلم انه عليم بذات
الصدور
ويقللكم في
اعينهم واذ يريكموهم اذ التقيتم في اعينكم
قليلا
ويقللكم في اعينهم ليقضي الله امرا كان
مفعولا ليقضي الله
امرا كان
مفعولا والى الله ترجع
الامور يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا لقيتم فئه
فاثبتوا واذكروا الله
كثيرا واذكروا الله كثيرا لعل لكم
تفلحون واطيعوا الله ورسوله ولا تنازعوا
فتفشلوا فتفشلوا وتذهب ريحكم واصبروا ان
الله مع
الصابرين ولا تكونوا كالذين خرجوا من
ديارهم بطرا
ورئاء الناس
ويصدون
ويصدون عن سبيل
الله والله بما اعمالكم وقال لا غالب لكم
اليوم من الناس
واني جار
لكم واذ زين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم وقال لا
غالب لكم اليوم من الناس واني جار
لكم فلما
تراءت الفئتان نكص على
عقبيه نكص على عق اني اخاف الله
والله
دينهم ومن
يتوكل سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
اللهن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصرا صراط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولو ترى اذ يتوفى الذين كفروا
الملائكه يضرب وون وجوههم
وادبارهم وذوقوا عذاب
الحريق ذلك بما قدمت
ايديكم وان الله ليس بظلام
للعبيد كدا بال فرعون والذين من قبلهم
كفروا بايات
الله كفروا بايات لله فاخذهم الله
بذنوبهم ان الله قوي شديد
العقاب ذلك بان الله لم يك مغيرا نعمه
انعمها على قوم حتى حتى يغيروا ما
بانفسهم وان الله سميع
عليم كدا بال فرعون والذين من قبلهم كذبوا
بايات
ربهم كذبوا بايات ربهم فاهلكناهم
واغرقنا ال
فرعون فاهلكناهم
بذنوبهم واغرقنا ال فرعون وكل كان
عند
الله ان شر
الدواب عند الله الذين كفروا فهم لا
يؤمنون الذين عاهدت منهم ثم ينقضون
عهدهم ثم
يون فاما
تثقفن انهم في الحرب فشرد بهم من
خلفهم لعلهم
يذكرون
واما
تخافن من قوم خيانه فانبذ اليهم فانبذ
اليهم على
سوا
ان الله لا يحب
الخا
ئين ولا
يحسبن الذين كفروا
سبقوا
انهم لا
يعجزون واعدوا لهم ما استطعتم من قوه ومن
رباط الخيل ترهبون به عدو
الله ترهبون به عدو الله و
عدوكم واخرين من
تنفقوا من شيء في سبيل الله يوث
اليكم يوث اليكم
وانم لا
تظلمون سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم
[Silence]
اكبر الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
بس
الله
اكبر لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدلوا
استووا سووا
الصف الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال وان جنحوا للسلم فاجنح لها وتوكل
على الله
انه هو السميع العليم وان يريدوا ان
يخدعوك فان حسبك الله هو الذي ايدك بنصره
وبالمؤمنين
والف بين
قلوبهم لو انفقت ما في الارض جميعا ما ت
بين قلوبهم ولكن الله الف
بينهم انه عزيز حكيم يا ايها النبي حسبك
الله ومن اتبعك من
المؤمنين يا ايها النبي حرض المؤمنين على
القتال
ان منكم الف الفا من الذين كفروا بانهم
قوم لا
يفقهون الان خفف الله عنكم وعلم ان فيكم
ضعفا فان يكن منكم مئه
صابره يغلبوا مئتين وان يك منكم الف يغلب
الفين باذن الله
ان الله عزيز حكيم الله يريد الاخره والله
عزيز عظيم فكلوا مما غنمتم حلالا
طيبا الله ان حكيم حكيم ان
اولئك بعضهم
اولياء من
ولايتهم من شيء حتى
والذين كفروا بعضهم
اولياء
بعض الا تفعلوه
تكن فتنه في الارض
وفساد كبير والذين امنوا وهاجروا وجاهدوا
في سبيل الله والذين اووا
ونصروه
اولئك هم المؤمنون حقا لهم
مغفره
ورزق كريم والذين امنوا من بعد وهاجروا
وجاهدوا معكم
فاولئك
منكم واولو الارحام بعضهم اولى ببعض في
كتاب الله ان ان الله بكل شيء
عليم
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
براءه من الله ورسوله الى الذين عاهدتم من
المشركين فسيحوا في الارض اربعه اشهر
واعلموا انكم غير مخزي
الله وانكم غير معجز الله ان الله مخزي
الكافرين واذان من الله ورسوله الى الناس
يوم الحج الاكبر ان الله
بريء من المشركين
ورسوله
فان تبتم فهو خير لكم وان توليتم فاعلموا
انكم غير معجز الله
وبشر الذين كفروا بعذاب اليم الا الذين
عاهدتم من المشركين ثم لم
ينقصوكم شيئا ثم لم ينقصوكم شيئا ولم
يظاهر عليكم احدا
فاتموا اليهم عهدهم الى
مدتهم ان الله يحب المتقين فاذا انسلخ
الاشهر الحرم فاقتلوا المشركين حيث
وجدتموهم وخذوهم واحصروهم واقعدوا لهم كل
مرصد فان تابوا واقاموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه فخلوا
سبيلهم ان الله غفور رحيم
وان احد من المشركين استجارك حتى
يسمع كلام الله
ثم ابلغه مامنه ذلك
بانهم قوم لا
يعلمون كيف يكون للمشركين عهد عند الله
وعند رسوله الا الذين عاهدتم
الا الذين عاهدتم عند المسجد الحرام فما
استقاموا لكم فاستقيموا
لهم ان الله يحب
المتقين كيف وان يظهروا عليكم لا يرقبوا
فيكم الا ولا ذمه يرضونكم بافواههم وتابى
قلوبهم واكثرهم
فاسقون اشتروا اشتروا بايات الله ثمنا
قليلا
انه فصدوا عن سبيله انهم
ساء ما كانوا
يعملون لا يرقبون في مؤمن الا ولا ذمه
وا هم
المعتدون فان تابوا واقاموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه فاخوانكم في الدين ونفصل الايات
لقوم
يعلمون وان نكثوا
ايمانهم من بعد عهدهم وطعنوا في
دينكم فقاتلوا ائمه الكفر
انهم لا ايمان لهم انهم لا ايمان لهم
لعلهم
ينتهون الا تقاتلون قوما الا تقاتلون قوما
نكثوا ايمانهم
وهموا وهموا باخراج الرسول وهم بدوك اول
مره اتخشون فالله احق ان تخشوه ان كنتم
مؤمنين
قاتلوهم
ق قاتلوهم يعذبهم الله بايديكم ويخزهم
وينصركم عليهم
وينصركم عليهم ويشفي صدور قوم
مؤمنين ويذهب غيظ قلوبهم ويتوب الله على
من
يشاء ويذهب غيظ قلوبهم ويتوب الله على من
يشاء والله عليم حكيم احسبت ان تتركوا
ولما يعلم الله الذين جاهدوا
منكم ام حسبتم ان تركوا ولما يعلم الله
الذين جاهدوا منكم ولم
يتخذوا ولم يتخذوا من دون الله ولا رسوله
ولا المؤمنين
وليجه والله
خبير بما
تعملون ما كان
للمشركين ان يعمروا مساجد الله شاه
على
انفسهم بالكفر
اولئك حبطت
اعمالهم
واولئك هم
الخاسرون وفي النار هم
خالدون ان انما يعمر مساجد الله من امن
بالله واليوم الاخر واقام الصلاه واقام
الصلاه واتى الزكاه ولم يخشى الا
الله
فعسى
اولئك ان يكونوا من
المهتدين الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله الله اكبر
اكبر الله
اكب
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورح
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
استقيم الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اجعلتم سقايه
الحاج وعماره المسجد الحرام كمن امن بالله
واليوم الاخر وجاهد في سبيل
الله لا يستوون عند الله
والله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين الذين امنوا وهاجروا وجاهدوا في
سبيل الله باموالهم
وانفسهم اعظم درجه عند الله
واولئك هم
الفائزون يبشرهم ربهم برحمه منه ورضوان
وجنات لهم فيها نعيم
مقيم خالدين فيها ابدا ان الله عنده اجر
عظيم يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا
اباءكم
واخوانكم
اوليا ان استحبوا الكفر على
الايمان ومن
يتولهم منكم
فاولئك هم
الظالمون قل ان كان
اباؤكم
وابناؤكم واخوانكم وازواجكم
وعشيرتكم
وعشيرتكم واموال اقترفتموها
وتجاره تخشون كسادها ومساكن ترضونها احب
اليكم من الله
ورسوله احب اليكم من الله ورسوله وجهاد في
سبيله فتربصوا حتى ياتي الله
بامره والله لا يهدي القوم
الفاسقين لقد نصركم الله في مواطن كثيره
ويوم حنين اذ اعجبتكم كثرتكم فلم تغن عنكم
شيئا وضاقت عليكم الارض بما رحبت ثم وليتم
مدبرين ثم انزل الله سكينته على رسوله
وعلى المؤمنين وانزل جنودا لم تروها وعذب
الذين كفروا وذلك جزاء الكافر ين ثم يتوب
الله من بعد ذلك على من
يشاء والله غفور
رحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا انما المشركون
فلا يقرب المسجد الحرام بعد عامهم
هذا وان خفتم عيله فسوف يغنيكم الله من
فضله ان
شاء ان الله عليم
حكيم قاتلوا الذين لا يؤمنون بالله ولا
باليوم الاخر ولا يحرمون ما حرم الله
ورسوله ولا يدينون دين الحق من الذين
اوتوا الكتاب حتى يعطوا الجزيه عن
وهم
صاغرون وقالت اليهود عزير ابن
الله وقالت النصارى المسيح ابن الله ذلك
قولهم بافواههم يضاهئون قول الذين كفروا
من قبل قاتلهم الله انا
يؤفكون اتخذوا احبارهم
ورهبانهم بابا من دون الله والمسيح ابن
مريم وما امروا الا ليعبدوا
ال واحدا لا اله الا هو سبحانه عما
يشركون يريدون ان يطفئوا نور الله
بافواههم ويابى الله الا ان يتم نوره ولو
كره
الكافرون هو الذي ارسل رسوله بالهدى ودين
الحق ليظهره على الدين كله ولو كره
المشركون الله
اكبر سمع الله الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
الله الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا ال
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا ان كثيرا من
الاحبار والرهبان لياكلون اموال الناس
بالباطل ويصدون عن سبيل
الله والذين يكنزون الذهب والف ضه ولا
ينفقونها في سبيل الله
فبشرهم بعذاب
اليم يوم يحمى عليها في نار جهنم فتكوى
بها جباههم وجنوبهم
وظهورهم هذا ما كنزتم
لانفسكم فذوقوا ما
كنتم تكنزون
ان عده الشهور عند الله اث عشر شهرا في
كتاب الله يوم خلق السماوات والارض منها
اربعه حرم ذلك الدين القيم فلا تظلموا
فيهن
انفسكم وقاتلوا المشركين
كافه كما يقاتل لونكم
كافه واعلموا ان الله مع
المتقين انما
النسيء زياده في الكفر يضل به الذين كفروا
يحلونه عاما
ويحرمونه عاما ليواطئوا عده ما حرم
الله ليواطئوا عده ما حرم الله فيحلوا ما
حرم
الله زين لهم
سوء اعمالهم والله لا يهدي القوم
الكافرين يا ايها الذين امنوا ما لكم اذا
قيل لكم انفروا في سبيل الله اثاقلتم الى
الارض ارضيتم بالحياه الدنيا من الا
اخره فما متاع الحياه الدنيا في الاخره
الا
قليل الا
تنفروا يعذبكم عذابا اليما ويستبدل قوما
غيركم ولا تضروه شيئا والله على كل
شيء
قدير الا تنصروه فقد نصر
الله فقد نصره الله اذ اخرجه الذين كفروا
ثاني اثنين اذ هما في الغار اذ يقول
لصاحبه لا تحزن ان الله
معنا
فانزل الله سكينته عليه وايده بجنود لم
تروها وجعل كلمه الذين كفروا
السفلى وكلمه الله هي العليا والله عزيز
حكيم
انفروا خفافا وثقالا وجاهدوا باموالكم
وانفسكم في سبيل الله ذلكم خير لكم ان
كنتم
تعلمون لو كان عرضا قريبا وسفرا قاصدا لا
بعوك ولكن بعدت عليهم الشقه وسيحلفون
بالله لو استطعنا لخرجنا معكم يهلكون
انفسهم والله يعلم انهم
لكاذبون عفى الله
عنك لم اذنت لهم حتى يتبين لك الذين صدقوا
وتعلم
الكاذبين لا يستاذنك الذين يؤمنون بالله
واليوم الاخر ان يجاهدوا باموالهم
وانفسهم والله عليم
بالمتقين انما يستاذنك الذين لا يؤمنون
بالله واليوم الاخر
وارتابت قلوبهم فهم في ريبهم
يترددون
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
استغفر
[Silence]
‏okej much
work
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك ودك محمد وعلى
اله وصحبه اجمعين ومن تبع باحسان ال يوم
الدين اما بعد
[Silence]
الله
صل so the st as
that
k
and because
aage
take
ليك
ose
all
[Silence]
‏things
things all
‏church and they fire over war and
someh
mistak to be reng they desty our place
we
goty so he takes know army
[Silence]
‏i come
are
‏came here saw man respect man as as
open
mou own
own
اللهانه الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتال ترى كيف ف ربك باصحاب الفيل يجعل في
وار عليهم طيرا ابابيل طرم حجاره من سجيل
فجعله ككول الله
[Silence]
الله
‏there
from
come and there st there st of this one
elepant you know they telling you know
telling withing
down
[Silence]
‏there from
tak
[Silence]
‏from اللهانه
وتالى from the come
this
[Silence]
‏while some you
so
[Silence]
‏first
حفا
تنش
[Silence]
‏come
‏from either say so tells us
to out lally every drop of the
sand there is not a ocean that will come
to quench my
thirst so say you to protect your own
today not send
another army of the to prot today he
say haram
‏he said we will come
holding flags of truth in our hands now
that's secondary thing there using
fls he said from our bl the poet on the
sander
[Silence]
علال
اله
الاحول اله مد رول الله ربنا اتنا في الدن
حسنه وفيره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا
عذاب القبر وقنا عذاب جنم وقنا عذاب فتنه
محمات وقنا عذاب فتنه المسيح الدجال ربنا
تقبل منا انك السميم وتب علنا الرحيمى
الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحه اجرحك
الرحمين الل امين اللهم امين اللهم
امين استقيم
واستو الله
اكبرك بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
انما يستاذنك الذين لا يؤمنون بالله
واليوم الاخر وارتابت قلوبهم فهم في ريبهم
يترددون ولو ارادوا الخروج لاعدوا له عده
ولكن كره اللههم بعاث فثبطهم وقيل اقعدوا
مع القاعدين
لو خرجوا فيكم ما زادوكم الا خبالا ولاو
ضعوا خلالكم يبغونكم الفتنه وفيكم
سماعون لهم والله عليم
بالظالمين لقد ابتغوا الفتنه من قبل
وقلبوا لك الامور حتى
جاء الحق وظهر امر الله وهم
كارهون ومنهم من يقول اؤذن لي ولا
تفتني الا في الفتنه سقطوا وان جهنم
لمحيطه
بالكافرين ان تصبك حسنه تسؤهم وان تصبك
مصيبه يقول قد اخذنا امرنا من قبل ويتولوا
وهم فرحون قل لن يصيبنا الا ما كتب الله
لنا هو مولانا وعلى الله
فليتوكل
المؤمنون قل هل تربصون بنا الا احدى
الحسنيين ونحن نتربص بكم ان يصيبكم الله
بعذاب من
عنده او بايدي
فتربصوا انا معكم
متربصون قل انفقوا طوعا او كرها لن يتقبل
منكم انكم كنتم قوما
فاسقين وما منعهم ان تقبل منهم نفقاتهم
الا انهم كفروا بالله وبرسوله ولا ياتون
الصلاه الا وهم كسالى ولا ينفقون الا وهم
كارهون فلا تعجبك اموالهم ولا اولادهم
انما يريد الله
ليعذبهم بها في الحياه الدنيا وتزهق
انفسهم وهم
كافرون ويحلفون بالله انهم لمن منكم وما
هم منكم ولكنهم قوم
يفرقون لو يجدون ملجا او مغارات او مدخلا
لولوا اليه وهم
يجمحون ومنهم من يلمزك في
الصدقات فان اعطوا منها رضوا وان لم يعطوا
منها اذا هم
يسخطون ولو انهم رضوا ما اتاهم الله
ورسوله وقالوا حسبنا
الله وقالوا حسبنا الله سيؤتينا الله من
فضله ورسوله انا الى الله
راغبون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين انما الصدقات
للفقراء والمساكين
والعاملين عليها والمؤلفه قلوبهم وفي
الرقاب والغارمين وفي سبيل الله وابن
السبيل فريضه من
الله والله عليم حكيم ومنهم الذين يؤذون
النبي ويقولون هو اذن قل اذن خير لكم يؤمن
بالله ويؤمن للمؤمنين ورحمه للذين امنوا
منكم والذين يؤذون رسول الله لهم عذاب
اليم
يحلفون ل يحلفون بالله لكم ان يحلفون لكم
انهم
لم يحلفون بالله
لكم ليرضوكم والله ورسوله احق ان يرضوه ان
كانوا
مؤمنين الم يعلموا انه من يحادد الله
ورسوله فان له نار جهنم خالدا فيها ذلك
الخزي العظيم يحذر المنافقون ان تنزل
عليهم سوره تنبئهم بما في
قلوبهم قل استهزئوا ان الله مخرج ما
تحذرون ولئن سالتهم
ليقولن انما كنا نخوض ونلعب قل ابله
واياته ورسوله كنتم
تستهزئون لا تعتذروا قد كفرتم بعد ايمانكم
ان نعف عن
طائفه منكم نعذب
طائفه بانهم كانوا
مجرمين المنافقون
والمنافقات ب بعضهم من بعض يامرون بالمنكر
وينهون عن المعروف ويقبضون ايديهم نسوا
الله
فنسيهم ان المنافقين هم
الفاسقون وعد الله المنافقين
والمنافقات والكفار نار جهنم خالدين فيها
هي حسبهم ولعنهم الله ولهم عذاب
مقيم كالذين من قبلكم كانوا اشد منكم قوه
واكثر اموالا
واولادا فاستمتعوا بخلاقهم
فاستمتعتم بخلاقكم كما استمتع الذين من
قبلكم بخلاقهم وخضتم كالذي
خاطوا
اولئك حبطت اعماله هم في الدنيا والاخره
واولئك هم
الخاسرون الم ياتهم نبا الذين من قبلهم
قوم نوح وعاد
وثمود وقوم ابراهيم واصحاب مدين
والمؤتفكات اتتهم رسلهم
بالبينات فما كان الله ليظلمهم ولكن كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون والمؤمنون والمؤمنات بعضهم
اولياء بعض يامرون بالمعروف وينهون عن
المنكر ويقيمون الصلاه ويؤتون الزكاه
ويطيعون الله
ورسوله
اولئك سيرحمهم الله ان الله عزيز حكيم وعد
الله المؤمنين والمؤمنات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
ومساكن
طيبه ومساكن طيبه في جنات عدن في جنات عدن
ورضوان من الله اكبر ذلك هو الفوز العظيم
يا ايها النبي جاهد الكفار والمنافقين
واغلظ عليهم وماواهم جهنم وبئس
المصير يحلفون بالله ما قالوا ولقد قالوا
كلمه الكفر وكفروا بعد اسلامهم وهموا بما
لم
ينالوا وما نقموا الا ان اغناهم الله
ورسول
من
فضله فان يتوبوا يك خيرا لهم وان يتولوا
يعذبهم الله عذابا اليما في الدنيا
والاخره وما لهم في الارض من ولي ولا
نصير الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكب الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغ
ضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ومنهم من عاهد الله لئن اتانا من
فضله
لنصدقن
ولنكونن من
الصالحين فلما
اتاهم من فضله بخلوا به وتولوا وهم
معرضون فاعقبهم نفاقا في قلوبهم الى يوم
يلقونه بما اخلفوا الله ما وعدوه وبما
كانوا
يكذبون الم يعلموا ان الله يعلم سرهم
ونجواهم وان الله علام
الغيوب الذين يلمزون المطوعين من المؤمنين
في الصدقات والذين لا يجدون الا جهدهم
فيسخرون منهم سخر الله منهم سخر الله منهم
ولهم عذاب
عظيم ولهم عذاب اليم استغفر لهم او لا
تستغفر لهم ان تستغفر لهم سبعين مره فل
يغفر الله لهم ذلك
بانهم كفروا بالله ورسوله والله لا يهدي
القوم
الفاسقين فرح المخلفون بمقعدهم خلاف رسول
الله وكرهوا ان يجاهدوا باموالهم
وانفسهم في سبيل
الله وقالوا لا تنفروا في الحر
قل نار جهنم اشد حرا لو كانوا
يفقهون فليضحكوا قليلا وليبكوا كثيرا
جزاء بما كانوا
يكسبون فان رجعك الله الى
طائفه منهم فاستاذنتها
تقاتلوا معي
عدوا انكم رضيتم بالقعود اول مره فاقعدوا
مع الخالفين
ولا تصل على احد منهم ما ت ابدا ولا تقم
على قبره انهم كفروا بالله ورسوله وماتوا
وهم
فاسقون ولا تعجبك اموالهم وا دهم انما
يريد الله ان يعذبهم بها في الدنيا وتزهق
انفسهم وهم
كافرون واذا انزلت سوره ان امنوا بالله
وجاهدوا مع رسوله استاذنك اولو الطول منهم
وقالوا ذرن نكم مع
القاعدين رضوا بان يكونوا مع الخوالف وطبع
على قلوبهم فهم لا
يفقهون لكن الرسول والذين امنوا معه
جاهدوا باموالهم
وانفسهم
واولئك
واولئك لهم الخيرات واولئك هم
المفلحون اعد الله لهم جنات تج
من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها ذلك الفوز
العظيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالم
امين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
وجاء المعذرون من الاعراب ليؤذن لهم وقعد
الذين كذبوا الله ورسوله سيصيب الذين
كفروا منهم عذاب
اليم ليس على
الضعفاء ولا على المرضى ولا على الذين لا
يجدون ما ينفق كون حرج اذا نصحوا لله
ورسوله ما على المحسنين من سبيل والله
غفور
رحيم ولا على الذين اذا ما اتوك لتحملهم
قلت لا اجد ما احملكم عليه
تولوا تولوا واعينهم تفيض من الدمع حزنا
الا يجدوا ما
ينفقون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اك الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
الله استغفر الله
استغفر صلاه الوتر الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا ال
ضالين
امين
والضحى والليل اذا سجى ما ودعك ربك وما قل
ولا الاخره خير لك من الاولى ولسوف يعطيك
ربك
فترضى الم يجدك
يتيما
فاوى ووجدك
ضالا فهدى ووجدك
عائلا
فاغنى فاما اليتيم فلا تقهر واما
السائل فلا تنهر واما بنعمه ربك
فحدث الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الددين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليه غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الم نشرح لك صدرك ووضعنا عنك وزرك
الذي انقض ظهرك ورفعنا لك ذكرك فان مع
العسر يسرا
ان مع العسر يسرا فاذا فرغت
فانصب والى ربك
فارغب الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد وا اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا
طيبا مباركا فيه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه به
اجمعين اللهم احسن عاقبتنا في الامور كلها
واجرنا من خزي الدنيا وعذاب الاخره اللهم
جنبنا الفتن ما ظهر منها وما بطن اللهم
حبب الينا الايمان وزينه في
قلوبنا وكره الينا الكفر والفسوق
والعصيان واجعلنا من
الراشدين ربنا لا تزغ قلوبنا بعد اذ
هديتنا وهب لنا من لدنك رحمه انك
انت
الوهاب ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر واجعلنا من
عتقائك من النار ومن
المقبولين اللهم انصر اخواننا المستضعفين
والمجاهدين في كل مكان وفي فلسطين وفي غزه
يا رب العالمين اللهم اطعمهم من جوع
وامنهم من خوف اللهم انزل سكينتك ورحمتك
ومددك وعونك عليهم يا رب
العالمين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
ان